[Music]
hi everyone welcome to simplify and
secure your network for all workloads
I'm Stephanie Wong developer Advocate
and with me here today is maninder
zombie VP and GM of cloud networking
welcome in Ender thank you Stephanie I'm
really excited to be here I'm really
thrilled to be part of the Google Cloud
infrastructure networking team
networking as you know Stephanie is the
fabric that interconnects all workloads
in a very secure simple as you migrate
workloads into the cloud or you're
modernizing your applications
for the last couple of years we have
shipped a lot of Innovations many of
them being best of cloud and I'm here
together with Stephanie to introduce the
next level of innovations that will make
it easier for our customers to move
migrate their workloads into the cloud
as well as modernize their applications
great to have you here Amanda
now customers across all Industries and
regions run their workloads on Google
Cloud Network today and our Network
infrastructure has become the foundation
that fuels our customers businesses from
Healthcare retail Financial Services
media and entertainment to public sector
Enterprises of all sizes and segments
are transforming and building businesses
leveraging the scale security and
simplicity from Google Cloud Network
and the network is constantly expanding
we are building out our Network to reach
more customers than ever and enabling
them to connect with global scale lower
latency and higher throughput to enable
digital businesses globally
we've expanded with 35 regions 106 zones
173 Network Edge locations and are
connecting customers across the
continents via 22 high-capacity subsea
fiber cables that bring together users
in more than 200 plus countries
and our network has been 100 carbon
neutral since 2007. on top of this
Global Network infrastructure that
Stephanie talked about we are building
the best of cloud Network Services
to accomplish this we have defined our
Three core principles that help guide
our best practice
number one being meeting the customer in
the journey our customers are on
different phases of their journey into
the cloud and every customer is
different we are committed to meeting
our customers with the right Solutions
no matter where they are in the journey
second everything that we build we're
going to leverage that IP that Google
has around AIML and power up these
Network Services so we are actually
integrating AIML into our networking
services to deliver intelligent learning
detection mitigation and observability
as Network conditions change for example
we integrated ml with our Cloud armor
which enabled the fastest DDOS Direction
and prevention in the world we also
believe that security has to be built in
not bolted on so we built in security as
part of our design and collaborating
with the Best in Class Partners to bring
these Technologies to our customers an
example is about Google IDs which is
very catered towards the sock buyer that
is code developed with the industry
leading technology partner Palo Alto
Networks
with these core principles in mind
Google network is pleased to launch and
announce how we are enabling a simpler
developer friendly Network that is
secure trusted
flexible resilient services that can
support all type of workloads on a
global scale Network
today Stephanie and I are really pleased
to share some of our latest Innovations
in networking that will help our
customers in four key areas on how do
you Migrate how do you modernize how do
you secure and observe your workloads
into the cloud so let's take a look at
some of the new capabilities that help
customers migrate as customers migrate
services to the cloud we are now
simplifying how the services are being
secured and consumed with private
service connect something that we call
internally as PSE PSE allows private
consumption of services across VPC
networks that belong to different groups
teams projects and organizations and
this was done before using a layer 4
connection today we are actually
introducing a layer 7 or an L7 PSE that
provides consumer controlled security
routing and Telemetry to enable more
flexible and consistent policy for all
our services
with PSE hybrid producers and consumers
may now securely connect and access
managed services from the cloud or
on-prem making it easier to consume the
service anywhere
we are also excited to add new partners
to our ecosystem starting from confluent
data breaks data Stacks grafana neo4g
we're very excited about bringing these
partners that enables our customers to
easily consume data and analytics from
our partners today working closely with
our partners to deliver this integration
of PSE data Stacks confluent data breaks
found the integration to be effortless
and seamless and these are some of the
quotes that we are actually introducing
from our partner perspective we are
thrilled to integrate support for all
these partners and are looking forward
working with our customers to add more
and more third-party services many
customers have HPC workloads that demand
the highest compute and network
performance that is needed
we are proud to introduce the industries
leading 200 gbps networking with line
rate VM to VM PSP encryption supporting
the latest C3 machine family that we
have
with the 2x of bandwidth for a C2 VM
family our networking technology now
delivers low latency high throughput for
performance for the most demanding
workloads such as Financial Risk
modeling simulation scale out analytics
AIML and data processing as part of
their transformation Journey customers
are modernizing to achieve greater
business outcomes
I'm pleased to be joined by our great
customer of ours who is partnering with
us to transform their business into the
cloud please welcome Omar Hassan vice
president of operations for app Lovin
thank you thank you Stephanie I'm really
excited and glad to be here
so how has Google Cloud
helped you in this in this journey into
the cloud
yeah of course it's been an amazing time
uh working with Google Cloud we've
started our journey in early 2021 and we
were able to migrate all of our
applications seamlessly and across five
different regions in a single day wow
five regions in one day yes it was an
amazing and it was very
simple and easy to use the the Google
Cloud infrastructure
that's that's pretty amazing five data
centers a single day no pressure
so what results have you seen as you
migrated your workloads into the cloud
and how is cloud networking helped along
this journey yeah of course earlier this
year we made our migration to Google
Cloud CDN and there we saw better
performance
and we were able to in doing so scale up
traffic by three times in a short period
of time
the Google Cloud load balancers were
able to handle millions and upon
millions of uh requests instantly
and you know for us that consistent
performance and availability is very
important to us and our customers
and along with that I'm hoping you got
some cost reductions of course yeah uh
you know that that goes without saying
yes
So Not only was it like modernizing your
applications and making them Cloud
native
uh obviously the cloud brings in the
cost reductions but better performance
lower latency and scale at a global was
was really interesting
as you look at business outcomes I'm
sure these these led to business
outcomes that your company valued could
you give me a few examples of what those
business outcomes were yeah of course I
mean with lower latency we're able to
just provide that consistent performance
again we were able to take on more and
more customers which allowed our company
just to scale
um and along with moving to Cloud CDN we
were able to have better failover
capabilities a single paying view to our
infrastructure
and be protected through Google Cloud
armor
that is amazing I'm sure there's a lot
of customers who are viewing this
looking at the challenges of moving five
data centers in a single day while
having to provide business continuity
the resiliency and scale that is needed
in the performance to making sure that
your application continue to run getting
modernized to meet those demanding uh
business requirements
so you're not alone Omar I'm sure
there's a lot more people like you who
are going through this Journeys glad to
see the cloud infrastructure innovations
that we bring are helping you so thank
you Omar for joining us today we deeply
appreciate the partnership with you and
your company as you are on this Cloud
journey of course thank you Melinda
thank you Stephanie thank you Omar thank
you
well thank you so much to Omar and
muninder for bringing on app Levin it's
such a powerful example here
like applevin many customers are
similarly migrating to Google Cloud to
deliver Rich high quality experiences to
their viewers with personalized user
experience
we are introducing end-to-end monetized
streams through media CDN with two new
capabilities
media CDN now supports Google ad manager
Dynamic ad insertion which provides
customized video ad placements for
industry-leading ad decisioning with
live stream API media CDN can stream
live video content and optimize them for
delivery across client devices media CDN
is available in more than 1300 cities
which is ideal for running custom code
closest to users for Optimal Performance
introducing Network actions for media
CDN Network actions is a new product
that enables programmability for
customers to build and run serverless
functions in front of the cache nodes on
media CDN it gives customers the ability
to customize their delivery
infrastructure by programming and
running custom code to enhance secure
and manage their end user experiences
common use cases include additional
security controls improve cash offload
right custom logs and much much more we
built Network actions on developer
friendly open source Technology based on
web assembly and open apis one of our
key customers using media CDN is
Paramount streaming has become a
strategic initiative and growth area for
Paramount who migrated traffic to Media
CDN they observed consistently Superior
performance and offload metrics enabling
them to engage subscribers with the
highest quality viewing experience next
let's dive into security
just a few months ago we announced that
we prevented the largest layer 7 DDOS
attack
and this is powered by Cloud armor with
Cloud armor we prevent threats against
web services leveraging our AI ml
technology to detect protect our systems
and our infrastructure Cloud armor
provides a service for advanced
protection of web applications services
and apis against DDOS attacks and L7
attacks from fraud to bots at a global
scale and does so for hybrid multi-cloud
architectures we recently announced a
cloud armor expansion that now includes
protection for CDN applications
non-http use cases
we also announced that cloud armors ml
based adaptive protection capability
combined with the recent rate limiting
feature were instrumental in mitigating
an https attack of 46 million requests
per second which was 76 percent larger
than the previous reported record next
we have delivered significant
enhancements and expansions to our Cloud
firewall offering Google Cloud firewall
helps you achieve a zero trust Network
posture via fully distributed Cloud
native firewall service with Advanced
protection capabilities and granular
controls you can even achieve interest
subnet micro segmentation which is
applied independently of the network
structure we recently announced new
enhancements that simplify configuration
deployment while simultaneously helping
to improve network security posture and
doing it at Cloud scale we have
introduced these capabilities in two
offerings Essentials and standard let me
give you a rundown on what these
services are
essential service forms the foundation
of the cloud firewall family
the enhancements here include the new
network firewall policy construct Global
and Regional security tags objects that
IEM governed and address group objects
taken together these features
simultaneously help increase policy
precision and simplify rule creation and
operation at a global scale
the cloud firewall standard offers an
advanced Dynamic curated object for
firewall rules that simplify policy
configuration and micro segmentation
to protect your Cloud workload and
infrastructure
the new Cloud firewall standard
introduces the following Advanced
Dynamic objects Google Cloud threat
intelligence with five different object
types
to start both known as well as unknown
malicious bad actor IPS and also known
useful IP sets like Upstream CDN
providers and search engines
number two
the domain name based on fqdn or dynamic
objects
and honestly making it geo-based Dynamic
objects
in summary here we see the two Cloud
firewall offers
the combination of IEM govern security
tags in Essentials
the dynamic objects in the new standard
tier and our existing hierarchical
firewall rules that help you run a very
flexible least privileged self-service
environment that enforces pinpoint
policy with greater Simplicity and
decreased operation Cycles observability
is critical to Monitor and troubleshoot
the network with network Intelligence
Center many of our customers are
leveraging real-time observability with
modules including Network topology
performance dashboard firewall insights
and connectivity tests Network analyzer
is our latest module which proactively
detects common issues such as
misconfigurations of firewall rules
routes connectivity and more and network
analyzer is now GA customers can now
receive log based alerting to address
potential issues very quickly
performance dashboard has been enhanced
with network visibility for customers
with latency metrics for Google Cloud to
internet traffic and in addition we
added a new top talkers view in network
topology so that customers can quickly
identify and monitor their largest
contributors to egress and optimize
those deployments for performance or
cost
we went through a lot of new updates
here and for more information here are a
few other networking and security
sessions if you want to dive a little
bit deeper
thank you Stephanie Cloud networking has
a lot of new exciting innovations that
you heard from me and Stephanie
these Innovations will help our
customers like yourself migrate and
modernize your workloads into the cloud
secure and observe all type of workloads
thank you so much Melinda I had so much
fun here with you today and thank you to
everyone else watching and for being
with us today
thank you